good morning ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much for being here with us
Commissioner wah Tchaikovsky just gave
his speech at the conference he will now
say a couple of words of introduction
and then we will be taking questions
from you
thank you very much thank you for for
your comment and interest about our
conference for me it was opportunity to
have the first presentation of my ideas
of challenges which I have made my plans
for the future and of course the most
important task for me now there is to
continue the work about there in a form
of Common Agricultural Policy as you
know we have the proposal of the
previous Commission mr. prepared by mr.
Hogan that there is no idea to propose
something new from the Commission side
but we are open for the changes for the
amendments during the further
legislative procedure first of all
because this is the problem for the
farmers there to describe more precisely
eco schemes I'm open for this this this
proposals from the farmers I I had a lot
of discussion with farmers organization
with copic Osaka for example the
previous weekend and I know that farmers
expects the more more information about
the this nature of eco schemes and
and environmental measures my very
important task is to prepare action plan
for organic farming which is very
important very important for the
European Green Deal we have different
situation with with member states they
are member states in which organic
farming is developed very well we have
member state since this is just
beginning of development despite of
Agriculture there is a problem promotion
of the of the organic food the
consumption of organic food is also
different we we have member states in
which is almost 10% of the market and
they are member states which is less
than 0.5% the promotion of organic food
is very important task the I said during
the conference that is very important
issue the problem of concentration of
land the three percent of the owners
they have majority fifty-two percent of
total area of Agriculture allant in
European Union we should prevent this
this two big concentration there is a
problem of to prevent corruption in you
you agree funds that we will propose any
recommendations for member states that
to prevent corruption to to introduce
more transparency in expenditure of the
EU funds for for agriculture okay they
are the the most important things oh
sorry it's about the budget this is very
important that you know that we have the
budget proposal presented by the
Commission of mystery uncle and this is
365 billion euro proposed for the seven
years financial period and farmers are
not very happy about this proposal my
duty as a member of the Commission is to
protect this budget but as I said during
the conference I will protect this
budget for and against the proposal to
reduce the budget because I have
experienced as a former members of
European Parliament I remember debate
about the budget for the previous
financial periods and it was always
final decision that was worse than
initial
basel of the commission i will protect
the budget at the hope that this time
will be different but i will protect the
budget against proposal to reduce this
safety budget but not against proposal
to increase the budget we need more
support for farmers we expect more
contribution of European agriculture to
European Green Deal this is very
important contribution of European
agriculture European farming to the
European Green Deal but more
contribution agriculture for Green Deal
means more support for agriculture this
is this is obvious and to achieve that
the old goals of the European Green Deal
requires more support for for
agriculture thank you please thank you
very much commissioner for this
additional words we will now take
questions we only have one microphone so
you will have to ask you to go to the
microphone first question yes please
Angela member from an Italian news
agency in a new tense trade environment
us farmers are flooded with subsidies in
the U the reply is a slight cut in the
CIP budget and no new tools or risk
management for farmers how do you want
to do you think this little problem oh
and how do you want to manage this you
know that a member of the European
Commission of the position of the
Commission is we have budget proposal
now the budget general budget of the
European Union and budget for the CIP is
on the hands of the Member States that
this is the question of the political
will of the Member States final
the site about the budget we have very
serious debate now I also participate in
this debate I my role is to to give the
real picture of the European agriculture
there are needs of the European farmers
I do this all time that and I hope that
final decision will be positive for
agriculture respecting the situation
which you say that in the international
trade for example our agriculture should
be more competitive absolutely and but
decision is in the hands of the of the
Member States
I hope that for the political agreement
for the political compromise and for the
budget which will be appropriate for the
for the needs which we have thank you
good morning mr. commissioner and thank
acquit from France and the European
Court of Auditors noted that the budget
used to finance direct payments to
farmers calculated on the number of
actors was not sufficient to address the
many environmental issues so are you
going to reform it you know that that
that reform is the proposal of reform is
on the table this is the mr. Hagen
proposal that we have the draft of
regulations and the place for to discuss
about this will be that at the moment of
time will be the approval of the
National strategic plans as you know
that one of the key points of reform is
more flex flex ability for four member
states and this is the role member
states to propose also in the direct
payment because in the past we had only
the rural development programs not not
special for direct payments now the
response will be one strategy plan for
both pillars of the common
agricultural policy this is very
important role of the Member States and
our role as a commissioner will be to
discuss with member states to to approve
national strategic plans maybe to
propose something changes if will be not
fully going to the right direction but
national strategic plan see this this is
the this this moment for to discuss all
this Thank You commissioner good morning
Commissioner my name is Tomas British
working for tapa god Germany and the
Polish Edition as well but they don't
speak Poland I have to I have to confess
I would like you to weigh the question
on the budget I didn't get your key
message right you told in the opening
speech that there will be no new a
proposal for the budget from the
underlying Commission this is clear but
at the same time you emphasize that you
will circle for for a strong budget but
if you if there's no new proposal so you
accept the cut as proposed from the
previous Commission under Tina or do you
support and now on the table the
negotiation box position of the of the
Finnish presidency which lowers the cut
in the aquaculture ponds thank you I
think that that my message was such such
clear at what what is possible in this
this stage of the debate about the
future budget and you know that there is
no new proposal from the from the
Commission I accept this that we have
the draft of budget and we have no time
to start from the beginning discussion
about the budget because we are under
pressure of the time but this debate is
is continued we discuss I also discussed
about the budget with unique many many
politicians meetings and
I hope that this time different and in
the past the final decision will be will
be positives for the farmers but of
course I cannot to declare something too
I cannot do promise because this is not
the question of the signature of the
Commission for agriculture it will be
the result of the very difficult the by
political debate and they key decision
is on the hands of Member States
governments of what do you expect from
the EU heads coming together in Brussels
this week sorry expect from the heads of
states this week coming to Brussels will
there be a breakthrough well I'm I'm
waiting for the results definitely think
no that there is no special expectation
now that that that but I hope generally
that the better understanding for the
farmers needs sometimes I can observe
that not that is not not my objections
against the politician sense but but
generally the there is the the problem
that farmers need not are not always not
by all society understands their needs
my role is to explain better that what
about farmers needs Thank You
commissioner we will be taking another
couple of questions I think two or three
no more interest of data Thanks hello my
name is Natasha I'm from you active and
it's clear that you have a strong focus
on organic farming could you please
elaborate on the ways that you will make
it easier for consumers to access
organic produce this is the consumption
is the the barrier for for development
of organic farming in Union in Europe
that this is the different experience
from the different situation in Member
States I can say about my previous
experience from my country Poland this
is a lot of farmers who are interested
to to be organic farmers to do
change they farm for for the do Toto
achieve the status of the organic farm
but the problem is market that problem
is how to sell their products and
solution is in the second pillar of the
Common Agricultural Policy there we have
we should have the instrument for
intervention to support organic farm but
not also the farmers but promotion of
organic food we have we should have more
more attention to the promotion of the
organic food this is the chance to to
improve the situation I will take to
develop an eco massage or a menorah
Nakash I represent the countryside
magazine which is published by the
European landowners organization and I
would like to come back to the length
concentration question can you elaborate
a little bit how you would like to
organize this work next year I imagine
and coming also from Eastern countries
the bigger problem is land consolidation
so how do you plan also to include that
in your work thank you the Mandate of
the European Commission at my Monday it
is limited in this this this this
subject this matter the structure of
ownership of plant is this is the
national competence according Article
345 of the treaty this is 100 percent
national competence but we can organize
kind of of exchange of information
exchange of good practices this is the
big problem for example when I was a
added or member of the court of Auditors
I wasn't responsible member responsible
for the audit about the young farmers
and young farmers in Europe were asked
what is the the first problem for you
to develop your yoga forms that the
first answer was access to the today to
buy land to increase their daily farms
and we should help them I think that
they are interesting practices in member
states the situation is different in
member states they are exchange of good
practices this it should be the bet that
our our answer in this document thank
you
Thank You Commissioner last question
film O'Neal Irish farmers Journal I
listen to interest commissioner when you
spoke about wanting to shorten the
distance between the the farm and the
fork you reference the amount of grain
that is coming in - ayah this come in
from the Americas in light of that then
do you have a concern about the level of
access that is in the Americas or deal
for more beef to come in from South
American countries which effectively
displaces European Union production from
the marketplace yes of of course that
that I know the problem the Mercosur
especially for the Irish Irish farmers
the beef producers I Island not only in
Ireland but I I know that it is very
sensitive problem for for farmer farmers
in Ireland maybe one of my first visit
will be to to our that you to recognize
better the situation at what we can do
but from other side I can observe the
this phenomena that we say a lot of
about the outside markets outside the
European Union okay this is very
important to promote our products to
give possibility to export our products
to the other markets but we have also
internal market in in our countries and
like may be interesting for you that in
Poland in my home country Poland the
consumption of beef is only two
kilograms per per one one person per per
year Poland is big big exporter of the
of the beef but the national consumption
is very small this may be this is not
only that the
polish phenomena but we take more
attention to the to the promotion new
production on the our internal market
there is a lot of to do and this this
this this area and especially for
therefore the Irish farmers for the
situation after Marcus or it needs
special special interests and I can say
that I am interested in very much about
the situation how to help concretely for
therefore the farmers who are affected
by the results of Mercosur and not other
trade agreements thank you thank you
very much to the Commissioner first of
all and to all of you for being presence
by